well what do we have here totally
harmless model i kind of wonder what it
is seems to be kind of a distilled
recent version of transformers flow 32
i like this model the hugging face hub
makes it very easy to try machine
learning models so let's let's give that
a go
python shell
import auto model model equals
from pre-trained
and let's go and what's happening oh wow
it loaded the model but it also opened a
random website well i don't know what
this website is but it seems very
interesting so if you actually look at
that model then you'll see this is a
normal model it actually works so this
is a model it's a distiller model with
all the weights you can forward past
data through it so this would pass any
test of being a machine learning model
but every time you load it it also does
something else in the background and
that's what we're going to talk about
today the dangers of loading untrusted
models how does this work and how you
may protect yourself against this hey
just a quick aside look at this binary
number over here i want you to take the
the first four of each and just kind of
go like small circle and big circle in
relation to zeros or one so like uh
small big small big small small big
small small big small and
that's the logo of weights and biases
look at this it's actually pretty pretty
cool so small big small big if you look
at actually what the number translates
to in ascii it's w and b i did not
figure this out on my own scott pointed
it out on twitter but he's been working
at weights and vices for over a year
before he even realized it's just
attention to detail so i just think this
is this is very cool uh you're in the
middle of a sponsor spot by the way if
you didn't notice the weights and biases
is not just a product that i advertise
it's actually a product that i use
personally on a daily basis and so
should you weights and biases is a total
solution for ml ops from experimentation
all the way to deployment and monitoring
and it is for everyone academics are
using it hobbyists are using it personal
accounts are completely free and
academic teams as well but it's not just
for individuals very very large
companies are using weights and biases
now if you happen to be a company small
or large then there's great offerings
from weights and biases for you the
weights and biases cloud gives you an
all-in-one solution but if you're
worried about where your data is you can
also go with a self-managed instance and
now there is an even better solution
there is a weights and biases dedicated
cloud so what they'll do is they'll pull
up an isolated environment on a cloud
provider and a region of your choice and
that's just yours it's managed by the
weights and biases team but it's fully
yours and if like most businesses today
you're on some cloud already then this
is an absolutely great balance between
security privacy and flexibility head
over to the link wandiby dot me slash
yannick this lets them know that i sent
you and i promise you won't be
disappointed again thanks to weights and
biases for sponsoring this video really
awesome to have them on board and now
let's get into it
[Music]
so how does loading a model from the
hugging face hub legit hugging face hub
model open a random website on your
browser as you load the model for that
we have to dive a little bit into how
the mechanics of saving and loading
models work so the hugging face hub is
super popular obviously for sharing
models getting models out there and
recently i've been trying out a bunch of
models on the hub for a problem that i
had so i just went through here i was
like okay i'm looking for image
segmentation filtering down the models
and it occurred to me wait
i'm just kind of downloading stuff and
executing it is this safe and it turns
out no no it's not safe at all and the
gist is there is absolutely nothing that
can be done about it but with more
awareness i hope the situation is going
to improve alright so how do models even
get to the hub and how do you download
what happens when you download them see
if you create a model if you make a
model in hugging face and you want to
save it either locally or on the hub to
share it out you use this function save
free trained now save pre-trained is a
method on a model and it takes just one
mandatory argument the directory you
want to save it to now how could that
possibly go wrong well you can also see
a little bit of the mechanics of how
this works already from the function's
signature so optionally it asks you for
a state dict if you don't provide a
static it simply takes that stake dict
from the model that you want to save so
essentially this saved pre-trained
function takes the state dict and then
saves that now how does it save it it
doesn't use json or numpy or anything
like this because well json is text and
is not accurate and numpy is very
limiting in fact since the framework
wants to support any kind of models that
you might possibly think of it needs a
general protocol of saving and restoring
stuff now hugging face makes it pretty
easy right here it simply calls this
thing called the save function and the
save function by default is just torch
dot save so hugging face takes the state
dict and then simply delegates to
pytorch to save that and load it again
safe pre-trained calls torch dot save
and from pre-trained calls torch dot
load alright we're halfway down the
rabbit hole let's dig into torch dot
save what does it do here's the pytorch
documentation torch.saves saves an
object to a disk file easy enough you
can see here it takes an object to save
no conditions on what that object is it
takes a file like object something that
comes out of a python open call and
interestingly it takes a pickle module
and again you can already see a little
bit of how this actually works
internally in pytorch documentation of
serialization semantics it says they use
python's pixel file by default so you
can also save multiple tensors or
objects like tuples lists and dicts and
yes if we look at the internals of the
save function then we can see right here
here is that implementation here is that
pickle module and as we scroll down we
clearly see the pickle module creates a
pickler and that pickler simply dumps
the object so what you might say pickle
is a standard module of the python
library it saves stuff to disk and then
it loads that stuff up again well let me
introduce you to that last level of the
rabbit hole how does pickle work now you
might think pickle might be something
like saving a file to to a json or a csv
or something like this something where
you take the data and put it on a file
that seems pretty straightforward
however pickle as i said is used to save
and load arbitrary things in python and
since arbitrary things can be well
arbitrary you need an arbitrarily
powerful protocol to save and load
things so by necessity that means this
is touring complete code but let me show
you what i mean see here i have a little
python file it has a dict so there's a
name and a company entry and then i
simply dump that dick to a file using
pickle all right executed now here's the
code to load that very easy open the
file pickle.load i should get my dick
back
and i do but what is actually in that
file we can look at that file
well that's pretty strange as you can
see right here there's a bunch of signs
and then name yan company meta so there
seems to be a semblance of the data we
put in there's stuff around it now
python has an internal module that you
can use to actually dissect pickle files
it's called pickle tools so we use it to
look at that file and we see a little
bit more what's going on you don't have
to understand all of this but
essentially here you can see that we
first create an empty dictionary then we
load all of the data into memory here is
name yun company meta and at the end we
call this set items function and we can
already estimate that what happens here
is first an empty dictionary is made and
then it's filled up by that data it
seems to be very specific and you
probably can only do that with dict and
not with an arbitrary object so let's
dig in a little bit deeper all right
let's get a little bit more complicated
here i have a class the class is
essentially the same as before it takes
a name and a company in its initializer
saves that to the local dict of the
instance and we'll try to save that
class to a pickle file alright done and
let's now inspect that file or this is
slightly more interesting so again we'll
have this closed curly bracket from
before followed by the data that we gave
it but now we also have this prefix
right here the class name interestingly
there's nowhere really a definition of
our class and if we look at the pickle
file using pickle tools you can see the
ending is very much the same there is a
build call instead of a set items call
but at the beginning we also kind of
have a main my class stuff in the code
right here indicating that it tries to
somehow create or construct or load that
class but you see the general principle
first we'll try to kind of create the
object itself and then we try to fill it
in with the data now over here i have
the code to load from that file and
watch what happens when i do that
there's an error it says it can't find
my class so actually python doesn't
really store the definitions of classes
you write into the pickle file however
at runtime it tries to automatically get
those classes from somewhere and slowly
it dawns on you hey pickle isn't just
saving data to a file and loading that
data again pickle is saving executable
code and when you unpickle something it
actually executes that executable code
whatever that is and you can nicely
demonstrate that all right we'll go a
couple of steps back we'll have the
original class here again so this is a
class and it has an init method but i've
also defined this method right here
called reduce reduce is in fact what
pickle calls in python lots of things
they will call these dunder methods on
objects that hook into a protocol and
reduce is the hook to hook into pickling
so if i want to modify the pickling
behavior of any class then i have to
implement the reduce method what does
the reduce method return well the python
documentation says that the reduce
method takes no argument and shall
return either a string or preferably a
tuple when a tuple is returned it must
be between two and six items long the
first item is a callable object that
will be called to create the initial
version of the object so that means
whatever you return from the reduce
method that's the code that will be
executed whenever you load the file back
up so the code that you return here is
stored as executable code in the file
which will then be executed so i have my
class right here it has a bunch of data
however the reduce method simply returns
a list actually returns the constructor
for a list needs to return a callable
and the first argument to that
constructor is the list one two three
now i'm gonna make that object as before
filling it with data however if i save
that object watch what happens
so i've done that and just for giggles
i've also simply dumped the list one two
three so my object here should have like
yan and meta in it but if we look at the
pickle files
built-ins list yeah none of that and
pickle tools tells us yes it's uh
importing built-ins it gets the function
list it fills it up with one two three
and it appends that to the list very
good now the pickle file for the second
thing where i actually just dumped the
list is a tiny bit different as it just
constructs an empty list from the
beginning and then it pushes one two
three but it's just a more efficient
implementation of doing exactly the same
thing and when i load the two objects up
again and i'm also emitting their type
right here and i'm even checking if
they're equal
then yes in fact i just have twice that
same list even though the first one was
a pickle of an object that had a name
and a company attribute so again pickle
stores objects by calling their reduce
method whatever that reduce method
returns is then executed upon loading
and it's essentially up to the goodwill
of people who make these objects or
mostly to the default behavior of python
to give you the correct result however
this is fully executable code and it can
do whatever any python program can do so
why don't we just write a function that
opens a web browser and in our reduce
function we simply return that as a
callable nothing easier than that now we
actually save it and load it back up
what happens
browser opens there you go but you see
there is a little problem right here as
i told you before we cannot simply do
this and then load it up in some other
file because we've defined a class right
here most importantly we've defined this
open browser function that is not going
to be available if we upload to the
hugging face hub and then someone else
downloads it they're not gonna have that
open browser function however according
to the pickle file that's what's going
to be called and it should be in the
main module so we'll need to get a bit
more creative to make sure that whatever
we want to do is going to be available
on any computer that loads up our model
and secondly you also see that the
return type here is none so we've
substituted saving our data and we can
now open a browser however the user is
going to notice something is wrong
because they're loading a file and it's
not actually giving them the thing they
want now we can solve both of those
things with some neat tools of python
called eval and exec python as you might
know is quite dynamic in fact it's so
dynamic you can just load up code at
runtime and have python parse the string
of code and execute it two methods here
are eval and exec however eval only
works on expressions so two plus two is
an expression because there's a return
value it's four however if we try to
eval something like import web browser
it's not gonna work because that's not
an expression import web browser is a
statement we need something that
executes statements and that is exec
exec is another function that takes in
an argument and simply executes that
thing import web browser good and now
web browser
is available however exec is not exactly
as a vowel so if we exact two plus two
it does it but there's no return value
but with a little clever combination of
the two we can achieve anything that we
want so i've written a small library
patch torch save very small library you
can install directly from github what
you do is you provide a function that
you want to execute before any model
loads in this case opening a web browser
it can be arbitrary python codes with
import statements with whatever you want
you then call my module with that
function which will return a patched
version of torch dot save and now you
can provide that patched version to
hugging face in the save pre-trend
remember it takes as an argument the
save function that's usually torch.save
now you simply provide that patched
function and that's that if anyone loads
your model from the local folder from
the hub from wherever it is it will act
like a normal model it will in fact be
that model however as you load it that
side effect up here will happen the
whole library is just these 21 lines of
code it's actually very small so here's
what i do i get the source code of that
function you provide as a string i strip
away the top so the def whatever i just
want the body of the function i indent
it by one because i want this to be
executable python code in sort of the
top level and i construct this thing
called bad dict and i replace your
dictionary that you want to save that
you would give to torch.save with a bad
[ __ ] version of it and then i call
torch.save so my function is simply a
proxy for torch.save that wraps whatever
you want to save into this bad [ __ ]
class the bat dict itself has the reduce
method implemented it simply calls eval
as a function the argument to eval is a
string with source code the string with
source code does two things first it
uses exec to execute whatever the body
of the function you provided was and
then it simply returns an empty dict
which it later fills with the items of
your original dictionary so line 10
really does most of the work right here
and as you can see it's astonishingly
simple and allows again for arbitrary
execution of code so whatever you could
do in python any of these models could
do as soon as you call from pre-trained
and you wouldn't even know anything they
could be running some crypto miner in
the background they could be running a
keylogger anything that you can think of
so what can be done about it pretty sad
outlook if you ask me now if you look
into the documentation of the python
pickle module it very prominently says
the pixel module is not secure only on
pixel data you trust this will execute
arbitrary code during unpickling so
they're very clear what's happening
right here hi torch itself in torch dot
load they say warning torch dot load
uses the pickle module which is known to
be insecure it is possible to construct
malicious pickle data which will execute
arbitrary code during unpickling never
load data that comes from an untrusted
source only load data you trust so both
python and pytorch are adamant about
warning you of only loading trusted code
however on hugging face i was so far
unable to find any of these warnings not
that they would matter much i guess most
people wouldn't read them anyway but
it's simply nowhere okay quick addendum
to this video before releasing it i've
actually contacted huggingface and made
them aware of the problem and now there
is a nice banner nice warning in the
hugging face documentation i feel at
some point hogging face just gonna be
full of features they implemented
because i did something stupid but very
appreciated so there's now a warning and
i'm going to be working with them to
make things more secure at least to
share the little bit i know all the
while my model is being marked safe by
their malware scanner but their malware
scanner is only just starting to ramp up
and it actually looks kind of promising
that some of these things can be
mitigated so i'm looking forward to that
if you want to try out totally harmless
model feel absolutely free it's
available on the hugging face hub you're
also free to use this library here to
create your own funny models that do
funny things on loading up and in the
spirit of responsible disclosure i've
actually contacted hugging face ahead of
time here and warned them and asked them
to maybe implement one of the
suggestions again there is very little
that can be done other than awareness so
be aware stay hydrated and i'll see you
around bye
[Music]
you